okay i think uh third time did the trick
sorry for all the stops and starts as i
mentioned uh this is all very um
impromptu and very improvisational but
yes now even this this dashboard that
i'm using says that i'm online on at
least facebook and youtube so i will
just keep going and and power through
this because i think there's a little
bit of a delay
between what i'm starting and stopping
so it's i'm pressing start it starts and
then everyone says it's working but that
by that time i thought it wasn't working
and then i started again but i think
we're good i'm just going to keep
powering i'm just going to keep bowing
through this so i'll start over just for
those of y'all who are wondering where i
am i'm in a walk-in closet off of my
master bedroom
because out here in california we have
these stay in place orders uh and as i
mentioned this is the walk-in closet
where khan academy all got started i
have uh spent a year in this walk-in
closet back in 2010 so i'm prepared to
spend at least
many weeks or months in this walk-in
closet if necessary
but as you can imagine a lot going on
for those of you that this is the first
time that you're coming to this live
stream
the whole point of it is
we obviously have these mass school
closures going on
and we at khan academy we find ourselves
in a somewhat unique situation of
realizing that this is what khan academy
to some degree was made for even though
we we've never really thought of this
circumstance actually happening and this
is clearly a very situation i don't
think anyone would want this the ideal
circumstances of the schools are open
academy is somehow a substitute for
live experiences we've always imagined
them being in partnership with
incredible teachers and classrooms and
you have your peers and you can liberate
the classroom to then go to higher order
tasks but we've also imagined khan
academy being used in parts of the world
where students might not have access to
school or might not have access to
certain
instruction or curricular material of
certain qualities and we now find
ourselves in a situation where most of
the world is going to find
ourselves in um
that that second that second uh category
uh so the um a couple of things are
are happening uh you know i've been
taking questions from parents teacher
students i would love to get more
student questions actually i know
there's some concern about the
cancellation delays of some of the sat
administration tests on friday we
released some schedules for students of
different ages and one thing that we
recommended for sure for high school
students is to use our official sat
practice obviously you can use this for
math you can
you can use us for
the sciences you can use this for the
social sciences but we also have the
official sat practice that we partner
with the college board on and
even if you aren't taking the sat or
even if now your sat has been delayed i
encourage you to think about using that
because it it covers math reading and
writing and it'll really make sure that
those skills don't atrophy even if you
aren't taking the sat anytime soon and
if if you do end up taking the sct in
the next three four months uh it'll be
it'll be really useful uh but
what uh i would love to do is make this
as interactive as possible i'd love to
take questions from all of you i see
let's see if i can scroll down here i
get a question
i'm a foreign student who's aiming for a
mathematics course in the usa what
courses exactly should i examine in khan
academy side are linear algebra and
multi-variable calculus needed and what
tests i need to take well muhammad uh it
depends what level you're coming into
the united states
it is
it is um i just saw a comment that sal
is getting old
we all get old
but the um uh the the it depends what
level if you're coming at the college
level uh you would probably have to take
something like the sat there might also
be things like the toefl which is
measuring your i think his test of
english language
um
test of english language fluency or
fluency language something like that
english fluency i i forget the acronym
but for those tests actually the level
of mathematics you need is not
overly advanced for the sct you really
the level of math you really have to
master algebra two and know it well
there's some tricky questions on there
but for the most part they're algebra
two questions uh and uh same similar for
the reading level uh reading
comprehension level things like linear
algebra or multivariable calculus which
are typically a freshman or sophomore
level course in college in the united
states are definitely not required for
entry level
into college obviously if you think
about graduate studies linear algebra
especially tends to be
applicable in a lot of the the technical
fields let's see other people
are asking questions
is khan academy in mountain view closed
as well
yes we have shut down the office it's
actually by law now unless you work in
our area in a you know healthcare
facility or grocery store or gas station
something that's considered essential uh
they're telling folks not to go to work
all right
so hi sal i'm a seven this is from basil
hi sal i'm a 17 year old high school
student and i've been teaching for
around three years for physics chem and
math do you recommend any sources to
improve someone's ability to teach
uh i i think
to it's a great question i've never had
quite that question the number one thing
is really mastery of the material
yourself
you know i think even for myself when i
first learned a lot of that material in
in high school and college i was a good
student and i understood it quite well
but it would be
it would be great if uh
but when i when i started doing khan
academy it it would um
and sorry for the team all these slack
questions are coming across and it's
making it a little bit uh disruptive
i'll look at the ipad in a second
but for the um
to learn uh how maybe to practice
teaching better obviously there's
nothing like teaching itself i i highly
recommend trying to make resources that
uh cover that material and i think
you'll find that you'll
learn the material a lot deeper and see
i'm going to go to the questions
that the team
is
looking at
okay
and so i'm looking at the doc team
and so i'm looking at the top of it
so yeah and
what's going on right now is our team is
looking at the various streams and then
they are curating the questions for me
to look at this ipad so
there's a lot of
homebrew things going on here but i'm
happy to
continue to answer questions i will look
at the stream that i see on this
dashboard
and see what other questions
people have
let's see
people have asked
um
i it seems like the quality is subpar my
apologies for that
well i will try to before tomorrow try
to find a place in the house that
hopefully has a better quality wi-fi i
have three full i have four full bars
here but i guess that's not doing the
trick
this is my first day that i'm doing this
at home so hopefully get better every
day
so please ask any questions the team is
looking at it they will update the stock
that i'm working from
i don't see any of the questions
uh just yet
so one questions jr gilroy asks will you
be leading a nationwide sat act study
session a great question jr
we
as part of our effort to support
everyone we are thinking about things
like that as you can tell even for this
live stream we're trying to figure out
the technology but i hope that over the
especially if this uh school shutdown
situation is protracted um if it keeps
going
i i hope that we can find ways to
support you in multiple subjects and
sat especially is an area that we might
be able to do either live streams or you
know large scale video conferencing and
help answer folks questions so i hope
that we can
go to something like that
any chance k
can students access kind of cutting
through gaming platforms unfortunately
that does not uh exist uh just just yet
let's see
um
other questions
okay
zapata says i've been assisting contest
students around me not just students
it's been helpful i'm so happy i'm one
of your ambassadors oh so for those of
y'all who don't know we have a thousand
teacher ambassadors around the world who
are teachers uh but they've been super
users of khan academy and they're also
in their region not just uh helping
their own students use khan academy but
they're helping other teachers help
their students i use khan academy so
thank you new yorker for for being one
of those uh teacher ambassadors and you
know one of the things that we're
brainstorming here at khan academy we
would love ideas from all of you and
especially our teacher ambassadors are
ways that uh teachers and i know
teachers are also sorting out their own
lives right now their kids are at home
they're trying to figure out how to
support their own students but if this
crisis or if the school shutdown
continues i hope we can find ways to
work with teachers who might be able to
volunteer to and not just teachers
anyone who might be able to volunteer to
help support students around the world
who right now are
feeling maybe a little bit socially
distanced uh and um and need more
support above and beyond what khan
academy can do
on its own our hope is you know we've
released those schedules on friday that
khan academy is able to
uh is we've been able to structure a day
so that students of most ages are able
to use khan academy for most subjects
but i hope we hope that that can be
supported with other things yesterday we
talked about ideas like if there's a
classroom or cohort of students who are
working on something at the same time
maybe they can share a video conference
link a zoom or a google hangout where if
any of them have questions they can go
on it could maybe be staffed by a
volunteer parent or by their teacher and
we're going to think about ways of we
might be able to do that at a larger
scale or maybe even give templates or
directions for anyone to be able to do
that type of thing once again none of
this is ideal but we're lucky that we
have access to technology and a lot of
resources that will hopefully if this
happened 30 years ago we would have been
a lot a lot tougher of a situation
so that's that's our hope
let's see
so i have a question here
does khan academy provide social
emotional programs
so
a khan academy historically has been
didn't explicitly do social emotional
programs we tried to make put some
social emotional best practices in our
product experience and even in our
content
what we're told people like our some of
our content because it just feels
relaxing and fun
sometimes improvised kind of like what
you're what you're seeing right now uh
and um
but what we've been doing over the years
is trying to think about other ways that
we can supplement our core content and
experience with social emotional
programs we've had programs at schools
like learnstorm the app khan academy
kids that has been recently launched
that that was about a year and a half
almost two years now that is for younger
students ages three to about six goes
through the first grade standards and
that does cover social emotional
learning above and beyond math reading
and writing that's just to develop some
of that you know how to how do you deal
with others cooperation and and and
build your resilience but that is
something that we hope to explore
further
over
over over time
and let's see
other
questions
that i might
let me see
someone kay gretz says do you think that
school will be cancelled for the rest of
the year
uh
i'm not an expert
although i'm i'm not 100 sure that that
anyone has a clear idea
right now
what i do know i i posted a video on
saturday about the virus itself and
about its spread
and if you look at the patterns in other
countries
the the peak cases
from the stage that and it depends who
i'm talking to in what part of the world
but if you're looking from an american
point of view it it looks like the
peak cases start to level off
about two or three weeks
after or maybe four weeks after
there's a serious
whether you call it a shutdown or a stay
in place like here in california we
haven't had a full shutdown we're
allowed to go outside
but
they are enforcing a stay in place so
there's only some very basic functions
that are in place
china and wuhan did a full shutdown and
so they probably saw pretty
good uh and it still took them two to
two to four weeks to get to a uh
leveling off period uh so in in places
like california where it's not as full
of a shutdown
i hope that can happen in that time
frame but even if you imagine that which
i think would be on on the more
optimistic sides of things uh it's not
that all of a sudden people are going to
open up all of the institutions at peak
because the worst thing you want to do
is that things start to level off and
then you open everything up and then
things go back exponential so my best
guess is that it's going to be
several weeks and you can imagine the
school year at least in the northern
hemisphere we have about two months left
two and a half months left so i think
it's it's quite a it's it's possible
that this goes uh through through the
end of the school year not not an expert
though
let's see
so
isaiah hong says hi sal
a fellow college student here
maybe i don't look so old to isaiah he
says fellow college student
how will i know myself if i have
mastered the material i've been studying
any tips or key indicators to know if i
have demonstrated mastery
well one of the key tenets for those of
y'all listening and don't know about
mastery and mastery learning at khan
academy is this notion of mastery that
in traditional academics often times
you're exposed to the material and maybe
you get app and then the class might
move on to the next subject and then
that gap and maybe it's in something
pretty fundamental it might be in basic
exponents now all of a sudden you go to
the next unit that's on negative
exponents on logarithms and you're
expected to understand it and so isaiah
i think there's two ways to think about
it there's kind of the general term of
mastery that people use in everyday
language and then there's the i can say
more academic version that we use called
mastery learning which is making sure
that you can learn at your own pace and
fill in all of your gaps so to answer
your question is how do you know that
you've mastered it
i think the question maybe is uh
mastered at a certain degree of of
knowledge
and that's why when you go for example
in math or in many of the sciences on
khan academy we have what we call these
mastery mechanics so that for
uh every skill you can
you get to familiar proficient or
mastered depending on have you done it
on kind of skill focused practice have
you done it
in kind of a context switching
environment on our unit test or our
course challenges so if you're in khan
academy and if you're in a course and
you get full mastery by doing the unit
tests the mastery challenges the course
challenges on that course challenge you
can get a 90 plus percent you will have
mastered that content as at least in the
modalities that khan academy is
presenting them to you if you want to go
even deeper in a subject especially in
something like math then i expect you
know then i would i would go after some
of the more multi-part questions you
know even for for some of things like
our ap prep we have
videos that go into deeper questions
that you really can't do in a multiple
choice in a free response modality
and there pause the video
before i work through it or one of our
video creators work through it and try
to work through it on your own and i
think if you're seeing that you'll have
mastered it i think the next level maybe
even above a mastery and this goes to a
previous question that someone asked is
teach the material to other people
that's really the best way to ensure
that you can master it because if you
can really distill it in simple ways and
teach it to others then i think you you
know the material
okay
other
other
question yeah my apologies uh the the
i've gotten multiple points of feedback
now that the internet connection here is
not good so i'm going to try to fix this
overnight and have a better internet
connection for everyone
tomorrow
so let's see other
other questions
kim mcdonald
is a parent and says is there an easy
way to learn how to make assignments for
my kids i'm new here and i want them
working every day
and so uh the simple answer is yes you
can make assignments on khan academy you
can actually register using the teacher
tools as a parent and then you can
either add your child on as one of your
students or you there's a little code
and then they can add you on as their
coach or their teacher and then once
you're a teacher if you go to any piece
of content you can actually see a little
um thing that shows up at the top that
says you can assign it and you'll only
have one student or however many
children you have so yes you can assign
content but i also encourage especially
in subjects like math let your student
learn at his or her own pace so that
they can master concepts at their own
pace time and pace and that for you to
support them answer any questions they
might have and and provide some
motivation
see other other questions
so someone asks hey sal it's really hard
for me to concentrate at home any advice
for finding motivation when you don't
have any outside pressure
this is a very good question and i think
this is something that we all face
especially now that most of us or all of
us are going to be working from home
but it's an important skill because
especially once you're out of school you
know my day i don't have someone saying
hey do this for the next hour then do
that for the next hour or sometimes i do
but the way i try to do it is
i i give myself a list of things that i
hope to accomplish in a given day or in
a given week and what i do is as i'm
able to hopefully accomplish some of
them and some of them are longer ranging
things that can't be done in an hour but
some of them are things that can be done
that hour and it could be in progress to
something bigger and what i tell myself
is if i can knock this stuff out then i
have earned you know a right to whatever
take a break go for a walk uh whatever
else i find that pretty motivating i
think it's also
motivating just remind yourself you know
this is your opportunity to really
invest in yourself
a lot of times i think teacher students
maybe have the wrong the wrong mindset
to school where they're uh they're kind
of just like oh i gotta be here what do
i have to do we have to realize school
is a massive investment in in you uh in
your capabilities and uh now that you're
home and we'll try to support you as
best as we can and try to come up with
more mechanisms to support you
but the simple answer is uh this this is
your chance to
build that other muscle not just the
algebra or the reading comprehension or
the signs but build them the muscle of
actually
learning how to learn and learning to
self
self motivate here which i think is in
some ways the most valuable
meta skill you can you can have in life
okay see someone asks i just missed a
question that was an interesting one
it says
what is let me get back on the
questions from the team
so you have another question
tips on how you make videos from for
students so i wish i could show you my
office right now which i'm not at
because of the stay-at-home orders that
we have here in northern california
but my setup is pretty simple i have a
basic laptop actually
this is the laptop that i've recorded
many khan academy videos on i have a 150
dollar samson microphone you could
probably find it online or
at a local electronics store it doesn't
have to be that one just something that
sounds a decent it's not a super all out
professional microphone and i use a
wacom tablet
to uh draw on so it's a
it's a tablet that you can write on and
it takes a little bit of getting used to
but i've been doing it for 10 years now
so i'm very used to it 14 years now
on top of that what i use is a drawing
program in the old days i used microsoft
paint then i ended up using other tools
now i use sketchbook pro as the art
program and then i use camtasia studio
to do screen capture
while i'm drawing on the art program so
that is how i make the videos uh kind of
the meta tips i would have if you want
to make videos is just get started i
think it's very easy to over plan or to
convince yourself you're not ready and
there's nothing like kind of jumping in
and getting started especially if your
audience is for people you know and you
care about i think it was a blessing for
me that khan academy started with my
cousins it allowed me to say all right
you know it's my cousins i'm just gonna
press record and uh see what happens
but i think that allowed the videos to
be more conversational to be a little
bit more comfortable i think you don't
want to be super improvised but a little
bit of improvisation is nice people can
recognize that it's not being
constructed by some corporation with
large focus groups etc etc it's one
human being trying to communicate with
another human being so i really
encourage you i can't tell you how many
i had friends that i tried to recruit to
make videos in the early days of khan
academy they're
brilliant people who know how to explain
things passionate about their subject
if i talk to them at a coffee shop about
it i'm like oh can i just record you
because the way you just explained
quantum physics is inspiring and really
easy to understand but then as soon as i
tried to make them do a video they would
get all tight and they'd be like okay
the next step is
what happened to you and i think
sometimes you can get into your head and
you're so concerned what other people
would think that everyone gravitates to
a safe space and they try not to be
themselves and they try to be what they
think other people think an expert
should sound like
so i i wouldn't do that i would try to
be yourself have your personality out
there uh and be vulnerable with with
your students and uh and and but you
know obviously feel very comfortable
with the material uh and i think it'll
it'll come out just just great
let's say let's see
jessica
swanepoel says not a question but wanted
to say my daughter followed the schedule
yesterday and loved it she was very
excited to get started again this
morning awesome that's great news to
hear because we put the schedules out
over the weekend and it's um it's it's
good to get feedback and you know
positive feedback helps sometimes
but negative feedback is good too so
everyone should be
encouraged to give negative feedback
critical feedback because that was our
first draft schedule for students and we
hope to refine it as we learn more so
also give us feedback if you say hey
that period was a little bit too long
for students of that age or actually she
wanted to do more but the schedule said
move on to the next thing or that break
was a little bit too long or we have
ideas for other parts of the schedule
let us know we would love to
make that schedule better and better
somewhat see heather johnson says is
khan academy free that's a question i
love to answer khan academy is free
that's why we exist we are a
not-for-profit organization with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere the next
question you might be wondering is how
is it free because it costs many
millions of dollars every year many tens
of millions of dollars every year to put
out even just our server costs are
seven million dollars a year and i have
a feeling based on some of the numbers
we saw yesterday that they're going to
be in excess of 10 million a year
shortly uh that's paid for by
philanthropic donations and so i will
say if any of you you know for those of
you who are in a position to donate you
can go to khan academy.org donate if you
find value from khan academy if you want
to ensure that it's up and running as we
go through this crisis that students
around the world who don't have the
resources or don't have access to high
quality materials uh you know think
about even five dollar ten dollar uh one
time or monthly donation
but that's how how we are free uh for
for everyone
let's see this is from dishonest abe
i i i respect your honesty in your in
your username
where do you get the emotional energy to
learn all the time
you know for me
learning actually gives me emotional
energy i i tell a lot of folks when they
learn that khan academy is now 200
person plus organization
you know they kind of imagine that i'm
your traditional ceo who might you know
sit in a board room all day and be in
meetings all day and and some of that
is is kind of true uh but i'm a fairly
non-traditional ceo
but for me and and all of that's really
important you know you have to have a
team that you get aligned that you can
work with that you can do big things
together because you're not going to be
able to do it by yourself and this is
true even beyond khan academy why before
partnerships and things like that but
for for my emotional energy for me to be
able to get into the walk-in closet or
go into my office and to be able to
learn some new
some new history or new science or just
to be able to communicate something that
i've always loved which is almost
everything i've ever learned
that's the stuff that puts me in a good
mood when when i come home and i'm
grumpy uh my wife will say you probably
didn't make any videos today it's
usually she's usually accurate i i'm
usually in a good mood once i've had a
chance to immerse myself in some
academic content and and i think the the
thing you have to appreciate is this
academic this content that you're seeing
in textbooks or khan academy
almost every concept someone had
dedicated their life to figuring out and
sometimes people dedicated their lives
to figure out and they couldn't figure
out they couldn't figure out how did
plants
how did plants grow how did they take
carbon from the air and use sunlight and
water to somehow store energy
you know how do we know that a squared
plus b squared is equal to c squared
people pondered this for sometimes
decades hundreds of years and you have
the answers and and it's all there and
you just have to decode it a little bit
it's like you're harry potter like
someone figured out all this stuff and i
can i can learn this magic without
having to having to go through all of
that and maybe one day push the frontier
so
i i dishonest abe i think uh i think
it's just you know if you look at the
right way it's an incredibly magical and
and and it could be a source of
emotional energy a learning versus a
drain on emotional energy
so you see maybe we have time for
one more question
and
you see the science enthusiast says my
sister is struggling with fractions
i want to teach her how can i teach her
in a way that she likes
so i think the number one thing so if
she's struggling with fractions i would
go to khan academy section on fractions
you can search on our page you can even
actually go to arithmetic the whole
arithmetic course on khan academy
there's a whole unit on fractions and i
would start at the beginning of that
unit and i would have her work on that
material while you were sitting next to
her don't answer the questions for her
you can give her a little little pushes
every now and then little nudges if
she's getting a little demotivated or
she needs a little bit of a reminder or
just to say well read the question again
what are they really asking and see how
she's doing if you think her question
her problem is really infractions then
try to just
answer any questions she might have but
always push her she has a question say
watch the video first make sure you know
let her build that sense of agency so
that she can learn to learn and you're
there to support her
but if the video isn't properly
explaining it or it's just not
resonating with her the hints to each of
the exercise items are not resonating
with her then it's a great time for say
okay well think about it like this but i
think the hardest thing when you're
doing it live is the patience
and i say that because people say i
sound very patient in the videos
hopefully i do uh but
you know sometimes when
when when it's you know when i'm with my
kids sometimes and i feel like i'm you
know i i think their brain is drifting
they're probably getting frustrated with
me because they're thinking dad's saying
the same thing over and over again
it's not making progress so
respect you know appreciate that she is
trying that she's not just drifting and
she's not listening to you and just
trying to be as patient as possible i
think that's where tutoring sessions
oftentimes break down the tutor gets
frustrated the the student gets
frustrated and everyone wants to walk
away so have that patience keep
motivating her and i think little by
little i saw this with nadia back in the
day in 2004 when i was tutoring her um
as long as you you keep that regularity
i think you are going to see a lot of
progress if you see that even at the
earliest fractions thing so even you
know adding two-thirds to one-third
somehow she has a some some difficulties
with things like that it might be from
gaps that are coming earlier in her and
her learning journey and some of the
more uh basic arithmetic
so that's another thing that you might
want to do is have her start earlier and
build some confidence that's one thing
we've been recommending on the schedules
is
having students maybe even start as
early as kindergarten for example your
sister i'm guessing she's a third or
fourth grade student
start around kindergarten and she'll get
through that super fast she might learn
a thing or two uh probably it'll take
her half an hour an hour to get through
kindergarten then first grade might take
her an hour it'll build confidence
she'll see that okay she can do this
then second grade then third grade if
she gets to third grade she's going to
start hitting uh her zone of proximal
development her learning edge so to
speak
and but she'll know that she's
approaching it with a very strong
foundation and the more that you can be
around there for her uh the better and
motivate her
so i will i think that's all for today
especially with all of the technical
difficulty thanks everyone for being
part of this uh i it's this is one of
the things that keeps me um happy in
this time of what we call here in the
the us social distancing uh to hopefully
stop the spread of this virus
but i really enjoy connecting with all
of you i hope that this provides some
form of connection in this time of
social distancing for all of uh all of
you as well and um stay tuned i'm going
to do this every day so that we feel
together we want to support you not only
on your learning journeys but just as
human beings this is something you know
one day someone will do khan academy
videos about this time in history uh
because it's i think it's it's
it's um
it's it's pretty interesting so i will
leave y'all and i'll see you tomorrow